una entrada más que triunfal y un
recibimiento con una ovación de pie
presidente
pero sobre todo para asegurar que en
momentos de cambios en el legislativo
estadounidense la ayuda no cese
financial
la asistencia financiera es también muy
importante y me gustaría agradecerles
Muchas gracias gracias por los paquetes
financieros que ya nos han dado y por
los que quizás vayan a aprobar y sobre
los que están decidiendo su dinero no es
caridad es una inversión en la seguridad
y democracia global que manejamos con la
mayor responsabilidad posible
los miles de millones de dólares que
Estados Unidos ha proporcionado a kiev
han sido cruciales para resistir ante la
agresión rusa y para que 10 meses
después Ucrania esté viva y pateando
telensky a Pelón congreso bicameral
ibipartidista pendiente de aprobar un
paquete de emergencia para Ucrania de 45
mil millones incluido en los
presupuestos de 2023 justo antes de su
llegada el gobierno de Estados Unidos
anunció un paquete de ayuda de 1850
millones de dólares decisivo para
Ucrania ya que incluirá misiles que
podrían repeler los ataques rusos contra
las infraestructuras ucranianas cuando
ya golpea el invierno un anuncio
acompañado de una promesa que Estados
Unidos no piensa abandonar a los
ucranianos
nunca estarán solos cuando la libertad
de Ucrania se vio amenazada el pueblo
estadounidense no dudó
Esta visita tan solo unos días antes de
Navidad ha estado cargada de simbolismo
además de ser la primera visita
internacional de zelensky desde el
inicio de la guerra en febrero a quien
han tratado como un héroe deja patente
una cosa Ucrania y Estados Unidos son
ahora aliados